Tối quan ngày 11h năm 2018, công an tính ra lai đã thương tin bà đầu vụ cứ tệ sản sế ra tại phòng rất dịch chả bá,
nâng thương mại của Vân Vì Convén, chiến em ra lai.
Theo đó, mà khoảng 12h dựa cùng ngày tại định trên, có hai đối tượng năm dưới mặt trong phục áo khó khó hãng gặp,
đừng muốn bà hiểm mổ xanh gặp, nghĩ vẫn sự giúp xem một tôn nhận hiệu y sây tờ.
Mò vào đen, bình số đối tượng sự giúp bệnh việnh bẩy hơi một bà một bà một thay,
mang theo một tối xe mổ xanh, giá bà lâu có, dừng xe chú phòng xe.
Cá hai đi vào trong khu vực các quay xong dịch trên thây hai đối tượng công vật mổ đàn,
hình giảng giống xung hắn không chế các dình bình xong dịch.
Lâm cho các dình bình hằng sự bỏ trẻ khỏi các quay xong dịch.
So đó, cà hai vào quay xong dịch lấy khoảng 1 phía tắm tỉ đồng dưới ra xe tổ phó phía hướng á bà hàng giống.
Ngay sọc tý tiếp dẫn thông tin vụ vụ vụ để tăng với ngọc sinh.
Phó giám đốc công an tỉnh, tuổi trường các quay kẻ xa đều tra trực tiếp chỉ đạo các đường bị như vụ và công an các xa.
Phong chi khai lực lượng truyết xe nóng đối tượng, tuổi thông tin, tài liệu, trường cứu để đều tra sử lý.
Công an tỉnh giải đỳ gị.
Quần chúng niên giân khi có thông tin liên quan đến các đổi tượng nếu trên kịt thời thông bà ngoài cho đồng chi thượng tả độ công sôn.
Phó chừng phong kẻ xa khí sự công an tỉnh giải lại.